today I wanted to talk a little bit
about the the models and the algorithms
we use for planning under uncertainty
for robots so how robots make decisions
when the world is against them the
world's always against robots Yeah Yeah
It's Tricky
sure probably the best place to think
about or the best place to start is a
shortest path algorithm so I think
that's I'm going to try and draw it and
just to warm up the drawing um so you
can imagine that you're starting off at
home and you're trying to get to work
and I should say that this is a an
example of stolen from a talk I saw a
few years ago and I'll give you the the
acknowledgments for that later but
you've got let's say the simplest
shortest path problem you've only got
one action so you can go by bike and
that might take you 45 minutes
and you can go buy car and that might
take you let's say 30 minutes and you
could go by train and maybe that takes
you 35. this is a kind of a standard
decision-making problem right we've got
two states so our states are being at
home or being at work and we've got
three actions so we can go by bike we
can go by car
or we can go by train we use these kind
of sort of State transition models
everywhere for robotics so if I'm
programming a robot to pick something up
or navigate between in a map the last
time we were together we're looking at
robots navigating through these graphs
and we we turn those graphs into these
kind of decision problems as well
so this is a kind of a model you could
use to decide well what route do I use
to get to work and in this case if we're
trying to minimize time or minimize cost
then we would take the the car option
which is 30. I'm going to do my teaching
what's the problem with this model too
simple it's too simple so it doesn't
reflect the fact that life is just yeah
the world can be against you so the
world can be uncertain
so the standard thing we do in robotics
is we take these what we call
deterministic models so this is a model
where the outcome is fully determined by
the state you're in so you know where
you're going to be and we can say well
we can actually we can make them more
complicated we want to reflect the
uncertainty so I'll draw a kind of a big
version First and we can think about
that so we imagine we take our action
which we might call car and that's still
going to cost us 30 or it's going to
take 30 minutes right that's my planning
model this is how we're going to model
the world but then what we're going to
think about is actually there are going
to be different outcomes so when I
execute this action so when I perform
that action in the world I can still
only end up in one of three different
states but they might be different
traffic levels so it might be light
medium and heavy that's kind of amazing
I've got in my car I've chosen to take
my car to work I've driven a little way
and I hit the motorway or whatever and
it's it's one of these traffic States
and then I can go to work from that but
what we could imagine is when we move
out of those States it's going to take
us a different amount of time
so what we might do is we might use that
to change our model so this is the basic
idea and what we would do is we would
assign different probabilities we might
say 20 of the time or 0.2 the traffic's
light 70 of the time it's medium Temps
at the time or probability of 0.1
there's heavy traffic so this is
reflecting some of that uncertainty some
of that complexity in the world this is
kind of the standard action model we'd
use and when we use action models like
this this is called a Markov decision
process so a Markov decision process is
States and actions just like a shortest
path problem except now when I take my
action there's a probability
distribution over the the the outcomes I
can reach I think we did Mark off
sometimes talks about the text isn't it
right yeah so Markov is a probabilistic
assumption when you've got a state it
doesn't need actions right it can just
be State transitions excuse me State
transition systems and what we do is a
mark of assumption says the probability
of an outcome only depends on the
current state so it doesn't matter the
history it doesn't matter what I was
doing before I chose to leave home the
only thing that determines that
probability is the action I'm taking
right now to be more formal you can
think of that as a sort of first order
Markov system and you can have a second
order Markov system which says the only
the current state and the previous state
um determine my probabilities but in
general if you think of someone like a
Markov chain if you're doing text
processing you can think about word
generation following probability
distributions and there you can think of
like one step so if I give you the
there's a probability of getting capped
or if you if I give you I am the then
you get a probability of getting
something different and if you take that
whole history if you make there'll be a
third order Markov assumption you'd get
a different probability distribution
over the word you'd get next that's
desperate says
um right so that's our kind of action
that's our action model and so we can
take this action model we can stick it
into the the graph we have before the
process we have before let's set this up
again
and we'll draw that little area at the
top that means this is our initial state
so just like a shortest path problem
we're going to start from somewhere and
we typically do this in robotics because
our robot has to be someone when it
starts thinking and we're gonna make our
whole world a bit more complex so I can
either go to the railway I can go by car
I can go by bike so these these actions
now really are reflecting the choices
I'm going to make to start with so not
necessarily getting on and doing that
but sort of making the decision that
this is what I want to do and maybe go
into that form of Transport so now car
is going to take one this is me leaving
the house and going to to my parking
space and finding what car Railway maybe
I have to walk a bit further to get to
the railway so that'll be a cost of two
and then we can start to put these these
um actions in so actually these arrows
should be dots and I can put in the the
action that we had before where we have
different traffic levels so light
we've got medium I'm going to start
abbreviating these things because my
handwriting is atrocious and will take
forever just watching me write words or
heavy and then down at the bottom down
here we're going to have work and I'm
purposely doing two circles here because
we cook this this state transition
system we have our initial state with
the Arrow coming in and I do these two
rings to mean this is where we want to
end up we call this an absorbing State
there's no there's no way to get out of
it when you're there and as this is work
that's a little bit depressing but there
we go and then we might have an action
called Drive
so our Drive action
is going to be deterministic
in that I can take it and it always
takes me to work but I can only take it
in certain States so I can only take it
once I'm in my car I'm only like to
drive then and we can use this now to
model the fact that we might get
different durations of travel
so let's say the heavy traffic it takes
me 70 minutes to get to work in heavy
traffic 30 and medium 20 minutes in
light and I think we have these
probabilities of 0.2 0.7 and 0.1 so this
shows me that if I go by car I get some
probability of these different traffic
levels and once I've experienced that
traffic level there's no turning back I
have to follow the car I have to follow
that action choice so use the car to get
to work and it might take a different
amount of time we're going to say here
the bike is deterministic so if I'm on a
bike I'm fully in control of the
duration it takes me so that will take
45 minutes so it's further by bike but
there's no uncertainty and that could be
interesting later in this example we can
say that when I go to the railway
station
well maybe 90 of the time it seems quite
unlikely the trait the train is there
it's ready to go and then it takes me
I've got an action which we'll call
relax because once we're on the train
we're happy and that's going to take me
let's say 35 to get to work and then 10
of the time
I have to wait so I'm in the waiting
room and then from the waiting room I
get to wait and then 90 of the time the
train comes ten percent of the time I
get to wait again so what's interesting
here is there's a kind of notion of a
Time step you can start to imagine that
I'm I'm looping
um I wait the train comes I wait the
train doesn't come and I repeat that
and of course if I get stuck in the
waiting room for too long
I could also choose to go home
and what's nice about that is that I get
to make another choice
so that might cost me two my waiting
maybe I wait for three minutes each time
so now I've got this big graph
and this is the Markov decision process
this is a process because I'm going
through a sequence of steps at each step
I have to take a choice over what action
to perform
and then that evolves the state so it
changes the state I'm in and we have
different probabilities of reaching
reaching different states that's kind of
still in some sense we can think about
this as the shortest path algorithm but
instead of a shortest path we call this
a stochastic shortest path because what
we want to do is reach our goal so we're
still trying to reach our goal but now
we're dealing with the uncertainty as
well this is a model this describes the
choices your agent could have so this is
the choices you might have when you're
going to work we could imagine I'm
building an autonomous vehicle and this
is you know it's an autonomous taxi
system and it has to decide how to take
you to work these kind of models really
capture what we the decision you know a
decision-making part of artificial
intelligence whether that's robotics
whether that's chat Bots all sorts of
stuff
um so the next question is really how do
we how do we solve this and there's
there's two answers or there's two parts
that answer the first thing is what does
the solution look like the second bit is
is what algorithm do we use
when you say what does it look like
you've been as in is it is it just a
simple number or is that yeah well so in
the okay what structure does the
solution have so if it was the shortest
path problem the the solution is a path
right it's because it and that's a
sequence of the actions you will take
from start to finish
um but in in a in an mdp in a markup
decision process we can't use a path
because when I take a step the world
changes probabilistically stochastically
so I I don't know what world I'm what
state I'm going to end up in so instead
of a path we have what's called a policy
so policy is a lookup table that just
says when you're in this state take this
action
and that state could be the States from
the problem or we could even augment
them so as the as these models get more
complex we might add extra information
into the state we could add the time of
day we could add
um you know how much time is remaining
before some kind of deadline
um how many times we've waited in the
waiting room might have been interesting
you can add extra to your state to help
make decisions but in general the policy
rather than just being a straight line
plan a sequence of actions it's going to
be a lookup table that says typically
what is the optimal action so what's the
best action to take
to achieve a particular specification so
a particular goal that you're trying to
reach
um when you're in this state
and you can think of for mdps there's
all sorts of there's a very rich space
of specifications the most common one
for something like this for a stochastic
shortest path problem is to minimize the
expected cost to goal
so the the expected cost is the average
cost so if I get if I'm going to work
you know every day for the rest of my
life and I have these these choices
um then actually having the expected so
the average cost kind of makes sense
because I get to make this I get to
execute the policy for this this problem
lots and lots of times sometimes I do
well sometimes I do badly but all of
that kind of evens out over the time
um so we could we could think about that
to start with
um so my goal is to get to work my cost
is the time so what I want to do is
minimize the cost
to get get to um to get to the goal and
so I need an algorithm that's going to
compute the the cost of the so we think
about the cost of the expected cost of
the whole policy starting from the
initial state which is going to be
similar and it affect thinking about the
average cost of a path from the start to
the end or the cost of the average path
not the average cost of the part the
other way around because the paths
change because of the probabilities the
way we solve this is with something
called a Bellman equation so the Bellman
equation describes how good a particular
action choice is so we need to think
about the different action choices
available to us in a state and we use
those we kind of value those choices and
those that we basically pick the best
action which in this case will be the
action with the lowest cost and we put
that in the policy which is also about
why we can't use things like a star or
dijkstra a star and dijkstra deal with
deterministic problems so they deal with
State transition systems that might look
a little bit like this but they assume
the actions are purely deterministic so
they produce past from start to finish
there's no probability there's no
probability yeah so they they assume
that when they take an action the world
changes in the wave of action behaves
there are kind of analogs for some of
these things in the probabilistic world
then the algorithm we'll get to is is it
has similarities to the way dijkstra's
algorithm Works
um and actually a star is a heuristic
search algorithm there are also
heuristic search algorithms for Markov
decision processes so they're classes of
algorithms that fit well together and
but for this we can't take dijkstra or a
star and say you know off we go if
you're thinking about just the average
cost then everything gets a lot easier
and we what we're basically going to do
is take all the the different we're
going to multiply the cost by the
probability of getting that cost sum
them up and that tells us really how
good that action is so it's just kind of
like it's almost like taking something
like a normal shortest path algorithm
and collapsing all of the actions into
an average action
but we have to do that recursively
because that each action takes me to
another state where I can apply a
different I have to make a different
action choice so we have this recursive
problem of my actions are only as good
as the states they reach
that's the kind of recursive part but I
also have to think about the fact that
that happens probabilistically which is
where this sort of averaging comes in
for the expected cost we can also think
about trying to limit the probability of
success or failure or the probability of
certain extremes I think we can talk
about that later
um the algorithms are much much harder
but but but super interesting and
actually don't those are the things you
care about when your boss says you have
to be here by 10 o'clock for a meeting
or your patience runs out if your
commute is longer than 45 minutes so
real world problems are much I think
real world problems are better captured
by those richer specifications I mean it
looks to me like the waiting room is the
sort of is the kicker here because it's
potentially you know quite a bit more
complicated right yeah so if you went
down the train route then you've got
multiple kind of nests of that right so
it depends on what problem you're trying
to solve so if we're solving expected
value if I build a policy to only
optimize the average cost of a journey
then the best choice is car I think it's
something like 33 or 34 for minutes
which is faster than bike which is 45
and I think train comes in somewhere
over 35 or over 37 on average so it's
more expensive than car cheaper than
bike but yeah the average thing is
interesting and this is where these
models become fun for Robotics and for
problem solving which is your by
choosing the car 10 of your Journeys
take you 71 minutes right which would
make you extremely late late for work if
in general you should be taking 30 to
40. so you you if you only solve for
average value then
10 of the time you're very late
and so what you can think about in these
kind of problems is different what we
call either specifications or objective
functions so if you're doing some
optimization you typically think about
the optimization the objective function
the thing you're minimizing or
maximizing
and in when we do planning or decision
making with these kind of models we
often phrase it as a specification that
which is a mixture of the goal you're
trying to reach and the constraints
you're trying to put on it yeah so for
instance you're trying to do it in the
shortest possible time but it should
never be longer that yeah that that's a
perfect example so if you try to do it
in if you if you say it can never be
longer than
um
yeah I'm going to say 60 because the
mass I remember the mass of this so if
you say it for 60 well you always take
the bike
because every everything else there's a
chance the car takes 70.
um there is a non-zero probability that
the train also takes longer than 60. so
there is a non-zero probability in the
if you take the train you're waiting
forever effectively
um but the bike is deterministic but the
bike is long so it's guaranteed to be
less than 60.
but it's guaranteed to always be 45 so
you're always going to be later than you
want to be
um the the kind of optimal strategy I
think to get in under 60
um guaranteed to get under 60 whilst
minimizing time is to go to the train
wait for three Cycles wait and then go
home and get the bike so effectively you
can think about the chance of getting
the train within three cycles and then
if you go any longer then it's going to
take you longer you know you'll violate
your deadline so then you go back to get
the bike but that's a those kind of
solution mechanisms are really I've
actually been in that scene yeah exactly
um it happens a lot particularly kind of
post-covered where you're like well I
could work from home but I should be
there oh the Train's late I'm just going
to go back and put my pajamas back on
but you need to think about what we call
an augmented State space you'd put the
time that you've waited into the state
and that allows your policy to include
actions you know I you think about
actions that I'm in the waiting room and
time is now at nine minutes and those
things that you do in your head going oh
god I've waited this long maybe the
Train's never coming you can Factor
those into the the decision making as
well
if you know exactly where you want the
robot to go you take the 3D map and then
you manually annotate it with the points
in this case we're doing it entirely
well the graph is built autonomously
using that that Lego representation so
you say what we call submitted Computing
in particular what we want is the